The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at MIT.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to lecture
number five.
In the previous lectures we
talked about the formulation
of the finite element method,
and we derived already some
element matrices.
I want to continue that
discussion in the next lecture.
However, now I would like to
spend some time with you and
discuss with you the
implementation of the finite
element method.
I would like to present to
you some important aspect
regarding the implementation
of the procedures that we
talked about already.
We derived the equilibrium
equations KU equals R in the
earlier lectures, where R, of
course, contains various
contributions due to body load,
surface load, and so on.
And we particularly pointed
out that that the total
structural stiffness matrix
is obtained by summing the
element stiffness matrices, as
schematically shown here.
This we refer to as the direct
stiffness procedure, and that
direct stiffness procedure is
also applicable to the load
contributions, where we sum the
element load contribution
into a total nodal point load
vector RB, and similarly for
RS and so on, which then
together make up the total
load vector R.
We pointed out that the
stiffness matrix of a typical
element M is obtained via
this relationship here.
Notice in this integer, BM is
the strain displacement
transformation matrix, CM is
the stress-strain law, and
here we have Bm transposed.
We're integrating this
part over the total
volume of the element.
The RB vector for element M
was written as shown here,
where FB are the body loads
per unit volume into the
coordinate directions
considered.
Of course, these FB loads are
a function of the coordinate
is the element, and HM
is the displacement
interpolation matrix.
We are once again integrating
this product over the total
volume of the element.
In both of these equations, we
have been dealing with the HM
matrix and the BM matrix.
Of course, the BM matrix, as we
discussed, is obtained from
the HM matrix by appropriate
differentiations and so on.
Now we pointed out that if we
had N number of degrees of
freedom in the total structure,
then our HM matrix
is of order k by N. Capital N,
the same N that we're talking
about here.
k is equal to 1, 2, or 3,
depending on whether we are
dealing with a 1, 2, or
3-dimensional analysis.
The BM matrix is of order l by
N, where l is equal to the
number of strain components
that we are
including in the element.
In a 3-dimensional element, for
example, we would have l
being equal to 6, because there
are 6 strain components.
It's important that we talk
here about capital N being
equal to the total number
of degrees of freedom.
This way, this KM matrix here is
a matrix of order capital N
by capital N. In other words,
this is an N-by-N matrix, and
this RB vector here is a vector
of length N. It's has N
entries this way, and of
course only one column.
Having here an N-by-N matrix and
an N-by-1 vector here, we
can directly assemble the
element contributions into the
global structural matrices
and vectors.
We can do this because this
matrix here has the same order
at that matrix here, or each
of the element matrices has
the same order as the total
structure matrix.
Well, in practice, this is,
of course, not efficient.
We are dealing with a
very large system.
The capital N that we're talking
about here might be
2,000, 3,000, 10,000, and it is
not efficient to calculate
here in a capital N-by-N matrix
for each element,
because we recognized already
earlier that a large number of
rows and columns are simply
zeros in this matrix here.
In fact, only those rows and
columns contain non-zero
contributions or non-zero
elements which correspond to
the element degrees
of freedom.
In practice, therefore,
we calculate
compacted element matrices.
We are calculating for element
M or for typical element M
matrix o order little n-by-n.
Notice that I left out
the superscript here.
And our RV vector would be an
n-by-1, lower case n, where n
is now the number of element
degrees of freedom.
The H matrix that we're using
and the B matrix that we're
using now is a k-by-little n,
l-by-little n, versus here,
k-by-capital N, l-by-capital
N. We talk here about the
compacted matrices, and these
compacted matrices contain
really all the information of
these, which we might call
blown-up matrices.
Because the non-zero entries in
these blown-up matrices are
all contained in the K matrix
that I talked about here.
What we need, then, in practice
is the K matrix, the
compacted matrix, with
connectivity arrays, in order
to be able to go through
this process here.
In order to be able to assemble
the compacted element
matrices into a global
structural stiffness matrix.
That is done by a connectivity
array, as I will be
discussing just now.
That is one of the important
aspects that I would like to
discuss with you in
this lecture.
Well, I have prepared here some
view graphs as before,
and let us look at the first
one here, in which I simply
summarize one through three
phases that we are going
through in a finite
element analysis.
The first phase consists of
the calculation of the
structure matrices K, M,
C, and R, whichever are
applicable.
Here I mean static dynamic
analysis, et cetera.
The second phase, then, once
we have established these
global structural stiffness
matrices, consists of the
solution of the equilibrium
equation.
Of course, this solution is
carried out differently in
static analysis and in dynamic
analysis, and I will be
discussing the solution
procedures that we're using in
later lectures.
Once we have solid state
equilibrium equations for the
displacements, velocities,
accelerations, we can
calculate the element
stresses.
The element stresses are then
obtained from the strain
displacement matrices and the
stress-strain law, together
with the displacement as a nodal
point displacement that
we have evaluated.
In this lecture, I really
want to discuss with
you only phase one.
In other words, how do we
calculate the structure
matrices whichever
are applicable?
This phase one can be
subdivided, again, into three
different steps, and
I summarize these
on this view graph.
The nodal point on element
information are read and/or
generated first.
Notice that I also included
generated here, because there
is much repetitiveness in many
finite element analyses, and
we want to take advantage of
that repetitiveness, therefore
generate information data
whenever is possible.
Then once we had the nodal point
in element information
read into the computer program,
we calculate the
element stiffness matrices.
The mass and damping matrices,
if they are applicable, and
equivalent node upon loads.
Once we calculated the element
stiffness matrices, we can
assemble math and damping
matrices, of course.
Also, we can assemble all of
these contributions here into
the global structure matrices,
K, M, C, and R. And I would
like to discuss this process
in detail with you.
Before going into the details,
let me mention that the
procedures which I will be
discussing this you are really
the procedures that are
used in the computer
program Sab and ADINA.
But very similar procedures
are also used in other
computer programs.
The first important aspect that
I like to mention to you
is that in a finite element
analysis, we have to define
what degrees of freedom
we want to admit
at the nodal point.
In other words, if we have a
finite element mesh such as
this one here, I will be talking
about that mesh in
more detail later.
Then if this is a plane stress
analysis, in other words, here
we have a cantilever plate,
say, subjected to a load
there, if it's a plane stress
analysis, I only want to admit
certain degrees of freedom
at each of these nodes.
We have nine nodes here.
For example, at these nodes,
there shall be no degrees of
freedom admitted, or else I want
to knock out all of the
degrees of freedom to simulate
the boundary condition along
here, and at these degrees of
freedom here, away from the
edge, I have two degrees of
freedom to correspond to a
plane stress condition.
Well, if I want to do that for
this analysis and similarly,
of course, I proceed in other
analyses, then I want to deal
with each nodal point in turn.
And here I have a typical nodal
point i, say, at which
we can have altogether a certain
number of degrees of
freedom, the maximum that I
might want to admit in a
computer program.
Now in Sab and ADINA, we admit
a maximum of 6 degrees of
freedom, however, we
might have more.
In piping analysis, we might
have generalized organization
degrees of freedom, such as we
are using in ADINA P, and then
we would have more degrees of
freedom at the nodal point i.
But let's talk now only
about 6 degrees of
freedom and the maximum.
I denote the first degree of
freedom as the U degree of
freedom, the second degree of
freedom as the V degree of
freedom, the third degree of
freedom as the W degree of
freedom, the fourth one as the
rotation about the x-axis,
shown by this vector.
Notice that here I'm talking
about a vector such as this
one here shown.
And theta Y is the fifth degree
of freedom, theta Z is
the sixth degree of freedom.
What we are doing then is to
define a matrix ID, or we call
it the ID array, identification
array, which
has a certain number
of rows and a
certain number also columns.
The number of rows is equal to
the maximum number of degrees
of freedom that we can
have in the analysis.
Now in this particular case,
we have 6 as the maximum--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
The number of nodal points,
of course, vary
from analysis to analysis.
They might be 1,000, 5,000,
or even more.
For each nodal point, we have 1
column, therefore 6 entries.
And for each nodal point, we
can use these 6 entries to
define whether a degree of
freedom is active or
non-active.
A degree of freedom is active if
stiffness is put into that
degree of freedom, if stiffness
is defined in that
degree of freedom.
Well, let us go through
a specific example.
Here we have a cantilever
analysis, cantilever plate
analysis, and here we have a
2-by-2 elements idealization
of that plate, containing
altogether 4 elements.
It's a plane stress analysis.
The loading on this plate is
while at temperature 100
degrees Celsius top, 70 degrees
Celsius bottom.
And there might be a
concentrated load, such as
shown here.
Et cetera.
But let us now focus our
attention on, how do we
generate the element matrices,
and how do we assemble these
element matrices into the
global structure matrix?
Well, this is a 2-by-2 element
idealization .
We notice the following.
We notice that we have
altogether 9 nodal points--
and let me use the
pointer here.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9 nodal points--
that with these 9
nodal points, we
have defined 4 elements--
element 1, 2, 3, 4--
that element 1 and 2 have the
same material properties, and
element 3 and 4 have the same
material properties.
Notice the Young's modulus is
here 2 times 10 to the sixth,
whereas it is 1 times 10 to the
sixth for element 1 and 2.
Therefore, we will have to
define two sets of material
properties--
one set for these elements,
and one
set for these elements.
We also notice that since
we have 9 nodal points
altogether, we could have a
maximum of 18 degrees of
freedom in a plane stress
analysis, because there are
two degrees of freedom in a
plane stress analysis for each
nodal point.
However, these 18, of course,
represent the absolute
maximum, which in a static
analysis, we could not use,
because we would have to also
constrain the element mesh
sufficiently to obtain a
solution, to have a stable
structure, in other words, while
the constraints here are
that at these nodal points, that
all displacement shall be
equal to 0.
Now let us look at our ID array,
the ID array which I
mentioned right here.
We will have, in other words,
9 columns here, because we
have 9 nodal points, and we have
our 6 rows here, because
we have a maximum of 6
degrees of freedom.
An active degree of freedom we
denote by a 0 in this matrix.
A non-active degree of
freedom we denote by
1 in this ID matrix.
We notice the following.
If I put here the number of
nodal points along, we have 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Of course, the degrees of
freedom here are U, V, W,
theta X, theta Y, theta Z.
Now, notice that what we are
saying is that only for nodal
points 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, and 9,
we have these as active
degrees of freedom.
In other words, At nodal point
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, we have
active degrees of freedom.
These will be active
degrees of freedom.
And let me finish these
here too on this side.
So we have these as active
degrees of freedom.
These degrees of freedom and on
this side are interactive,
because their constraint.
They are no displacement.
Of course, stiffness is coming
into these degrees of freedom
through, yes.
So we could have made these
active degrees of freedom.
However, in addition, we also
know that the displacements
are 0 there, so we make them
inactive on that basis.
The result, then, is that we
have to read into the ID array
as shown here.
This is the typical reading
that you would use in the
ADINA computer program.
Once in all of those entries
here, and zeros there.
Now the program knows that
corresponding to these zeros
here, we will have to set
up element equations.
In other words, actually, we
have to set up for each zero
one equation, one global
degree of freedom.
And the program that
goes through
this process as follows.
It searches through--
let me go once more back--
through these elements of the
ID matrix product that you
have been feeding into
the program.
It searches through it, and
replaces each one by a zero,
going down column-wise, and
each zero by a number.
It starts with 1 and goes on
consecutively to the maximum
number of zeros that
it encounters.
The final result, then,
is this one.
Maybe I can just put it on top,
only to signify here that
we had all of these now zeros
which we are ones before, and
some numbers in this
corner here where
we had zeros before.
Let me take the bottom view
graph out, and so now we see
what has happened.
We have 0s everywhere here and
equation numbers up here,
which have been generated by
going through the original
columns of the ID array from top
to bottom, and replacing
the zeros by numbers--
1, 2-- these were all ones,
we put zeros here--
3, 4--
put zeros here--
5, 6--
put zeros here-- et cetera.
Now, these are the degrees of
freedom that the structure
will actually have, and they are
defined because stiffness
is coming into each of these
degrees of freedom from the
plane stress element, and we
know them to be non-zero.
In other words, if we look at
our final element idealization
again, we find that these
vectors here are active
degrees of freedom, which
I pointed out earlier.
In fact, this is here degree of
freedom 1, this is degree
of freedom 2, which is at nodal
point 4, and here we
have degree of freedom 3, and
then 4, at nodal point 5.
And those entries are
just those here.
At nodal point 4, remember
nodal points along here.
So this is nodal point 4.
We have the first and second
degree of freedom of the
structural model.
At nodal point 5, we have the
third and fourth degree of
freedom of the total
structural model.
Et cetera.
Well, this is an important
aspect.
Let us now go on
to some further
aspects of the analyses.
We will use this later on, once
again, when we set up the
connectivity arrays
of the element.
Here is our finite element
idealization, once again.
And the next step now is to read
in also the coordinates
of all the elements and
the temperatures
at the nodal points.
Now with this coordinate system,
x, y, and z, as shown
here, the coordinate of all of
these nodal points can be read
indirectly.
You can read them up. if you
know the length from here to
there, being 60 centimeters and
being from here to there
40 centimeters, surely all the
coordinates can be defined.
And knowing that the temperature
is given here at
70 degrees Celsius and 100
degrees Celsius there, and
there's a linear variation
from top to bottom in
temperature, we directly also
define the temperature array,
as shown here.
These are the temperatures at
nodal point 1 to 9, x, y, z
coordinates at nodal
point 1 to 9.
Of course, this is input.
You have to input this to the
computer program, just the
same way as you have to
input to the computer
program the ID array.
But then the computer program
figures out what coordinates
of these arrays pertain to
the specific elements.
And that is done in
the following way.
Once again, here is our
element idealization.
Now we have read in the fact
that we want to have this as
the first 2 degrees
of freedom, then
this degree of freedom.
That we have already all
established, that we have
these degrees of freedom in
the finite element mesh.
The program knows
that already.
That it does know via the
reading of the information in
the ID array.
We also have all the coordinates
of the nodal
points, and we also have
the temperatures of
all the nodal points.
What we still have to now read
in is how an element is
connected to the various nodal
points given in the structure.
And that is the next
important reading.
Here for element 1, we know that
the node numbers are 5,
2, 1, and 4, and the material
property is number 1.
Let's go back once more.
For element 1, that is, this
element here, I want to use
this material property
set, and I call that
property set number 1.
Property set number 1,
also, for element 2.
But property set number 2 for
elements 3 and for element 4,
because these element
properties are
different from these.
Well, so element one
has nodal points--
I use the following
convention--
5, 2, 1, 4.
I go counterclockwise around.
So locally, I'm thinking of a
coordinate system lying in the
elements, such as shown here.
And this one here being in the
positive quadrant is my first
nodal point that I assign
to the element.
This is, therefore, the
local nodal point 1.
Let's put another little
picture here.
This is a local nodal point 1.
That's local nodal point 2.
That's local nodal point 3.
That's local nodal point 4 for
any one of these elements.
The local nodal point 1
corresponds to the global
nodal point 5.
2 corresponds to 2.
3 here corresponds to 1 there, 4
here corresponds to 4 there.
I say, therefore, that the node
numbers of the element
are 5, 2, 1, 4.
The element number 2, then, with
this convention that I'm
using, has nodal point
6, 3, 2, 5.
Well, let's look here.
We have here 6, 3, 2, 5.
Also properties at 1.
Let's go on to element
number 3.
Here with this convention,
once again, we
have 8, 5, 4, 7.
And now, however, the material
property set number 2.
Et cetera.
Now, once the program knows
these nodal point numbers, it
can figure out a connectivity
array.
And that is done using the ID
array that the program has
already established.
It's being done in the
following way.
Remember that, once again, nodal
point 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, and 9 correspond
to these columns?
Now, we know from this
information here that element
1 couples into nodal
point 5, 2, 1, 4.
Let's keep that in mind, now, 5,
2, 1, 4, and circle here 5,
2, 1, and 4, where this one here
is the first local nodal
point, this is the second local
nodal point, this is the
third local nodal point,
and that is the
fourth local nodal point.
That's important.
Well, if we look at that
information, then, recognizing
that the local nodal point 1
corresponds to the global
nodal point 5, we have to use
these two equation numbers
corresponding to the
first nodal points.
Let's put a little
picture up here.
You see what I'm saying
here is the following.
If this is local nodal point
1, that's 2, that's 3, and
that's 4, and if I know that
this local nodal point with
degrees of freedom, let's call
them little u and little v,
corresponds really to the global
point 5 with degrees of
freedom 3 and 4, then this u
must correspond to 3 here, and
that v must correspond
to that 4 here.
In other words, our connectivity
array which we
will be using is established
as follows.
For our compact matrix, we have
8 rows and columns, and
for our actual matrix that we
want to add into the structure
matrix, we notice that what we
want to do is take the first
row and column here, and add
it into the third row and
column of the structure
matrix.
The first one here, u here,
corresponds to 3 here.
The second one here,
which is the v,
corresponds to the 4 here.
In other words, the first
degree of freedom of the
element corresponds to the
third in the structure.
The second degree of freedom of
the element corresponds to
the fourth in the structure.
And that is shown right here.
The first one corresponds to
the third in the structure.
The second one in the compact
element stiffness matrix
corresponds to the
fourth degree of
freedom in the structure.
Now if we go onto the second
local nodal point, we see
zeros here, and these zeros
go directly into the
connectivity array.
The third one has also zeros
here, and the fourth
one has 1 and 2.
So our connectivity array, then,
proceeding in the same
way, is shown as given here.
These are the degrees of freedom
at the first nodal
point, this first local
nodal point.
These are the degrees of freedom
at the second local
nodal point.
These are the degrees of freedom
at the third local
nodal point, and these are the
degrees of freedom at the
fourth local nodal point.
In other words, what
I'm saying here
really is the following.
You see this here is
the third degree of
freedom in the structure.
This is the fourth degree of
There is no degree of freedom
here because we
have a support there.
That is that zero
and that zero.
There is no degree of freedom
here because we
have a support here.
0, 0.
At this node, we are talking
about the first degree of
freedom here and the second
degree of freedom here of this
structure, and that
is given here.
So if I have established the
8-by-8 stiffness matrix of the
element, I can directly use that
8-by-8 stiffness matrix
with this connectivity array,
and assemble the appropriate
contributions from that 8-by-8
matrix into the global
structure stiffness matrix.
The same process that
is applied to all
of the other elements--
let's look at one more
element here.
And element 2, as we pointed out
earlier, has nodal point
6, 3, 2, 5.
Well, what we then have to do
is look at our ID array.
6, 3, 2, 5.
And what we are seeing
immediately is that we have a
5, 6 here and a 3, 4 here.
So the first two entries in the
element array should be 5,
6, and the last two entries
should be 3, 4, because we
have all these zeros there.
And indeed, if we look at
our LM vector here,
that's what we obtain.
Similarly, we proceed for
the other elements.
This is the connectivity array
for element 2, for element 3,
and for element 4.
We can use that now to assemble
the element stiffness
matrices into the global
structural stiffness matrix.
Of course, the program figures
these out automatically from
the ID array and from you having
put into the program
the nodal points of
each element.
Let us look now at how do we
actually deal with the
stiffness matrix?
Well, if we look at a typical
stiffness matrix--
this might be a typical
one here--
we have this pattern.
Of course the matrix is
symmetric, and what we have
are some non-zero elements
clustered to the diagonal, and
some 0 elements out there.
It is convenient at this point
to define a half bandwidth of
the stiffness matrix.
That half bandwidth is defined
in the following way.
We ignore, first of all, the
diagonal element, and then we
identify the furthest off
diagonal element from that
diagonal element.
The furthest one from the
diagonal element defines the
half bandwidth of the matrix.
mK is the half bandwidth
of the matrix.
In some literature, we also
refer to the half bandwidth of
the matrix as mK plus 1.
But then remember that the total
bandwidth off the matrix
is simply 2 mK plus 1, because
the diagonal element only
occurs once.
Another way of looking at the
definition of the half
bandwidth is as follows.
If we go from the diagonal up
in each column, we will come
to an element above which
only zeros are.
Like in this case, for example,
there are only zeros
above K 4, 5.
And we do the same for each
all of the columns, and we
define the last non-zero
element, this one here, above
which all elements are
zero, as the skyline.
So the skyline is defined
as shown here.
This is the skyline
of the matrix.
The half bandwidth, then, is
equal to the maximum column
height minus 1.
In this particular case, you see
the maximum column height
is 1, 2, 3, 4, which
we have here also--
1, 2, 3, 4.
We subtract 1 and we
get mK equal to 3.
So this is the pattern that we
observe in an actual finite
element analysis.
What we would like to achieve is
that the half bandwidth is
as small as possible, because
then we know that our
numerical operations
is a solution of KU
equals R are small.
Well, the actual storage that
we're using, however, is a
little different.
Namely, it is effective to store
the total information as
a one-dimensional array.
And the storage, then, is
carried out as follows.
Notice that in a one-dimensional
array, I am
using now the following
convention.
This here is the first element
in the one-dimensional array.
The second element is this
k22, which is a2.
The third element is k12.
The fourth element is
k33, and so on.
In other words, the A vector
here, being a one-dimensional
vector, stores all of the
information here in a
one-dimensional order, where we
simply go from the diagonal
upwards to store all
of the elements.
So a6 is the diagonal element
that is the fourth column
here, a6 corresponds to k44, and
a7 then stores this one,
a8 stores that one, a9
stores that one.
Notice that we do carry
along these zeros.
And the reason for it is that
when we do perform our
solution of the equation, in
general, but not always, in
general, this zero becomes
a non-zero element, and
therefore it is effective to
just carry it along, because
we will have to later on
store some non-zero
information in it.
Notice that this is the total
array, and we have altogether,
in this particular case, 21
entries here, in addition to
storing the stiffness matrix in
this one-dimensional array.
However, we also have to have
an identification array that
tells us which elements in this
one-dimensional array are
diagonal elements.
Of course, here from this
picture, we see immediately
that these are the diagonal
elements of
the stiffness matrix.
However, imagine that we
simply store A as a
one-dimensional array
[? alone, ?]
then we would have to know that
a2 corresponds to the
second diagonal element, a6
corresponds to the fourth
diagonal element, and so on.
And that is done by
as a MAXA array.
You see, MAXA here stores
the addresses of
the diagonal elements.
Having MAXA, the array MAXA, and
having the one-dimensional
array that contains all the
elements of the stiffness
matrix strung out in one
dimension, we can access any
element in here during
the solution of the
equation as is required.
Let me mention one
more point--
that the length of this array
here is not equal to n, but
it's n plus 1, because this last
element here gives us a
diagonal element that would
occur out here.
So 22 really is this diagonal
element, which we really don't
have, of course.
But when we subtract 1 from it,
we get this element here,
or the address of this element
here, and then we know how
long this column is.
We have to know how long
this column is.
And for that reason, we need
this last entry here.
In practice, of course, what
we might find is that we
cannot store this total
matrix in [? core, ?]
because it's just too big.
There are just too many elements
in the matrix.
If we talk about a 5,000 degree
of freedom model with a
bandwidth of 1,000, then we
have 5 million elements in
that matrix.
And even on the very large-scale
computers now, you
have to somehow block that
information in order to be
able to deal with it.
And that we do in the
following way.
If a certain amount of
high-speed storage is
available, then based on that
high-speed storage available,
we simply block the total
stiffness matrix.
Once again, shown here.
Here is the skyline, or the
column heights are given by
that skyline.
We block it as shown here.
This is here block 1, this is
here block 2, this is here
block 3, and that is block 4.
In fact we will see, later on,
when we talk about the
solution of equations, it is
necessary that we can keep two
blocks at a time in the
high-speed storage.
In other words, if we have a
total high-speed storage of
40,000 elements, then 20,000
elements would be this, and
20,000 elements would be this.
Or in practice, of course, these
might be slightly less
than 20,000, and these
might also be
slightly less than 20,000.
But we have to be able to keep
two blocks in core, and that
is our criteria to determine
the block size.
Of course, the computer program,
once again, does all
that automatically.
It just knows how much storage
there is available, because
you have a specified amount of
storage that is available, and
then it allocates the
appropriate amount for each
block and calculates the block
size, the column heights in
each block, and so on.
Once again, I'm showing here
zero elements in a column.
When we actually decompose the
matrix as we do in Gauss
elimination into an LDA
transport form--
I will be discussing
that later--
we fill up these zero elements
in general, and that is the
reason why we carry them along
in the solution phase.
Let me make a few remarks on the
bandwidth, the use of an
effective bandwidth.
Here we have a finite element
model of a cantilever, a plane
stress finite element model
of a cantilever.
At each node, we have two
degrees of freedom, just as in
this earlier model that
we considered.
Notice these are now 8-node
elements, isoparametric
elements that I will be
discussing later.
We have constraint, of course,
at this end, all degrees of
freedom, because the cantilever
is 6 there.
In this particular layout,
notice we have used the
following element or nodal
point numbering.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 up to 13,
then from 14 to 20,
then from 21 to 33.
Well, this then means that
our bandwidth here, or
half-bandwidth, I should rather
say, and now let's
simply include the diagonal.
It doesn't make much
difference.
We are talking, in practical
analysis, about a bandwidth,
or half bandwidth, of 300.
So having 300 or 301, really, in
a practical analysis, makes
very little difference.
Our half bandwidth, including
the diagonal element here,
would be 46.
How would we obtain that?
Well, if we look at the coupling
between nodal points
that is due to the element
stiffnesses, we recognize that
for a typical element, let's
look at this element, we have
a maximum nodal 25 here, a
minimum nodal point 3.
Now, 25 minus 3 is
equal to 22.
However, we now have to add 1 on
because all of the diagonal
part, and that together,
then, gives 23.
This 1 I'm adding on because
of the diagonal element--
and if you where to look at the
stiffness matrix in its
assembled form-- of this element
in its assembled form,
you would see that this part
here is to be added on,
because you had also the
diagonal contribution.
So the maximum difference
between the nodal points plus
1 gives us 23.
Now, that 23 is a maximum if 1
degree of freedom were at 1
nodal point.
However, we take that 23 and we
have to multiply it by 2,
because we have 2 degrees of
freedom per nodal point, and
that then gives us 46.
So the half bandwidth, including
the diagonal, is 46.
Well, that is a very
large bandwidth, in
this particular case.
And let us now try to rearrange
the nodal point
numbering to come up with
a smaller bandwidth.
And the better nodal
point numbering
here is shown in layout.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, and
so on, down this way.
If we now look at the same
element again, the maximum
difference in nodal
points is 7.
We add 1 again to get 8, and we
have 2 degrees of freedom
per nodal point.
That gives us a half
bandwidth of 16.
And therefore, we have reduced
the bandwidth by almost a
factor of 3.
Now this means that the solution
effort will go down,
in the equation solution phase,
will go down by a
factor of 9.
Because he would see that
our solution effort is
proportional to the half
bandwidth squared.
So if there's a factor of 3
here, the solution will
actually be reduced
by a factor of 9.
Therefore, it is very important
to use minimum
bandwidth in the finite element
mesh, or rather number
the nodal point in such
a way as to obtain a
minimum half bandwidth.
If we actually deal with column
solvers, we will see
that in some cases we quite
don't want to have the minimum
bandwidth because we have a
column solver, about but these
are details that we will be
addressing in a little bit.
In general, we want to have
really a minimum bandwidth.
Let us look now at the overall
solution phase once more.
This is a solution phase in
the computer program STAP,
which is in the textbook that
you are using in this course.
You might look at the
description of this computer
program in more detail, but the
overall solution set is as
shown here.
We start the program, and we
have to read a nodal point
data, which involves
coordinates, boundary
conditions, and we established
the equation
numbers in an ID array.
I'll discuss that with you.
We then would calculate and
store load vectors for our
load cases.
We write these on tape.
If we have a typical analysis,
three, four load cases, we
calculate all of these
load vectors and
store them on tape.
Then we continue to read,
generate, and store element
data the way I've been
discussing this with you, and
in the actual analysis, we
loop over element groups.
By that I mean that the total
elements are subdivided into
element groups.
This is an effective concept
because in an actual
structural analysis, we deal
with plane stress elements,
beam elements, truss elements,
three-dimensional shell
elements, and so on.
And it is effective to just
group all of these elements
together into specific groups.
In other words, put the shell
elements together in one
group, the beam elements
together in another
group, and so on.
In fact, this is a very
effective way of proceeding
also in non-linear
analysis, in a
more complicated analysis.
If you're familiar a little
bit with ADINA, what we do
there is that we are grouping
elements not just together
according to the kinds of
kinematics that they're
representing, but also the
material models they are
containing, the kind of
descriptions we want to use
for non-linearities,
et cetera.
Well, having then generated and
stored the element data,
we can read it and calculate
the element stiffness
matrices, and assemble these
in a global structural
stiffness matrix.
Here we loop over all element
groups once again.
And this means generally we are
storing this element data
on tape, and then we are reading
it and going over all
of the element group data,
as shown here.
Then next we can factorize
the stiffness matrix.
This is a basic step in the
Gauss elimination procedure,
as I will be discussing
with you later.
And now we loop over the load
vectors for each load case,
read the load vector, and
calculate the nodal point
displacement.
We then read the element
group data and
calculate the element stresses.
Print out the element stresses,
and if there is
another load case to be
considered, we go back from
here into there.
So the LDA transport
factorization of the stiffness
matrix which was outside this
loop is only done once.
A forward reduction and back
substitution of the load
vector is done for each load
case, as shown here.
I will be discussing those
aspects in more detail later.
Let us now look at some typical
effective elements.
We have been discussing so far
some simple elements, just to
expose you to the basic concepts
that are being used.
And for that reason, we
discussed some very simple
elements in the earlier
lectures.
What I want to do now in the
next lectures is to discuss
this you modern, effective
isoparametric elements.
These are also the elements that
we are using in the ADINA
computer program.
Here we have a one-dimensional
truss element which can be
used as a cable element.
As a simplest element, it would
be 2-noded element.
We would only assign this
node and that node.
And then it would be, of course,
a simple 2-noded
truss, a very common element,
2-node truss.
However, as shown here, we can
also have a third note, which
is this one.
And we can have a fourth note.
In other words, what we will be
dealing with, really, are
variable number node elements,
which have two nodes, three
nodes, or four nodes for the
one-dimensional truss element.
A ring element is obtained from
the truss element in this
very simple way.
It's really an axis-symmetric
truss, you might call it an
axis-symmetric truss, with only
one degree of freedom.
It has only stiffness in its
circumferential direction.
So this is a truss element.
And the basic concept that we
are using is that we can have
a variable number of nodes.
Similarly for this element, this
is a plane stress, plane
strain, or axis-symmetric
element.
Notice that the only
displacement that we are
talking about in this particular
case are two
displacements, u and v, or in
ADINA, we call this the V and
W degree of freedom,
corresponding
to the y- and z-axis.
The z-axis is, in an
axis-symmetric case, the axis
of revolution.
And with this degree of freedom,
the kinematics of the
element are defined when
we talk about a
specific number of nodes.
And then the element can be used
for plane stress, plane
strain, and axis-symmetric
analysis, depending on which
stress-strain law you're
using, and which strain
components and stress
components
you're dealing with.
Here, too, we can use the
element simply with 4 nodes,
so we would have this
4-noded element.
We can also add another note,
make it a 5-noded element.
We can add this node, we have
a 6-noded element, now a
7-noded element, and finally
an 8-noded element.
The variable number node concept
is a very effective
way of formulating elements,
because the same basic
sub-protein basic element can
be used for all sorts of
different applications.
The same holds for
three-dimensional analysis.
There's also a bit of a number
node 3-dimensional element
where we have a basic number of
nodes being 8, and then we
would have this brick
element here--
let me just quickly
sketch it out.
This is the basic
brick element.
And now we can simply add
additional nodes in to obtain
higher-order elements.
And the 21-noded element here
is a very effective element
for general three-dimensional
analysis.
However, in some other
applications, even the 8-noded
element is quite effective,
effectiveness, of course,
being always measured by the
computational effort involved
in dealing with such an element,
and the accuracy that
the element can give us
in actual analysis.
So this being one element,
again, that can contain from 8
up to 21 notes, being a variable
number node element,
and being very effectively
formulated using the
isoparametric concept
that I will be
discussing in the next lecture.
Notice that in that concept,
we can have curved element
sides, as shown here, for the
higher order elements.
Finally there is, of course,
our beam element.
The beam element, which I'm sure
you are quite familiar
with, a simple 2-noded element
which might not be referred to
as a finite element, but on the
other side, we might also
call it a finite element.
Originally, it was not called
a finite element, but now if
we look at the basic
interpolation procedures that
we are employing, we may
very well refer to
it at a finite element.
Then the shell element that
I also will be discussing.
Here we have a basic shell
element that is shown here,
having 16 nodes.
At each nodal point, we have
now 5 degrees of freedom.
The 5 degrees of freedom being 3
translations, as shown here.
And in addition, 2 rotations,
these being the 2 rotations.
The 16-node element is the
highest order element that I
can recommend for practical
analysis.
It's a quite expensive element,
but very accurate,
because it admits curvature
into all directions.
So for curvatures, it can be a
very effective element to use.
Notice that at each node, we
have 5 degrees of freedom
where these translations are
defined in the xyz global
coordinate system, whereas the
rotations are not necessarily
aligned with the
x- and y-axes.
I will be discussing that
later on in detail.
But then with 16 notes and 5
degrees of freedom, we are
talking about 80 degrees of
freedom altogether, a very
considerable number for
a single element.
In practice, therefore, we
want to possibly use less
nodes on the element, and an
effective element that
directly is obtained
from this one is
simply the 9-noded element.
I will be discussing
that element.
And of course, this element and
other elements from this
one are directly obtained by
simply assigning certain nodes
to the element.
We use here again the variable
number node concept as we use
it for the truss element, the
2-dimensional, and the
3-dimensional element.
Another important feature that I
like to also just mention to
you is the fact that this
element can be used as a
transition element.
You might have a shell here,
and you might have a solid
here to be idealized, and
there's a transition region.
The solid element here would
have, in general, 3 degrees of
freedom at a node.
The shell element here has 5
degrees of freedom at this
node, 5 degrees of freedom at
this node, and here we have a
transition element that has
shell degrees of freedom at
these nodes, and solid degrees
of freedom at these top and
bottom nodes.
Here altogether at this line, 6
degrees of freedom, 3 here,
3 there, whereas at this line,
5 degrees of freedom.
So this is an effective way of
modeling a transition region
between a shell and a solid
in a compatible way.
In other words, preserving full
compatibility between the
elements, and not using any
constraint equations.
I will be also talking further
about this element later.
In this lecture, then, what I
wanted to discuss with you
were some basic concepts
regarding the formulation of
the finite element methods, in
particular regarding the
implementation of the finite
element method.
In other words, how do we
actually implement what we
formulated in the earlier
lectures?
Some of these concepts are very
important concepts when
it comes to actual practical
implementation of the finite
element method, particularly
the one that I discussed
regarding the connectivity
arrays that are
formulated, and so on.
This is all I wanted to say.
Thank you for your attention.